this video is brought to you by
portuguese pod 101
if you've always wanted to learn
portuguese there's no better time than
right now
and you can make it happen with
portuguese pod 101
click the link in the description to get
started with a free account
hello everyone welcome to the langfocus
channel and my name is paul
today we're going to focus on the two
major varieties of
portuguese real portuguese and fake
portuguese
now speakers of both varieties love me
because they're sure i just called the
other one
fake while still being varieties of the
same language
the portuguese spoken in brazil and the
portuguese spoken in portugal are
significantly different
in terms of pronunciation vocabulary and
grammar
brazilians often say it's difficult to
understand portuguese people
and portuguese people often say that
brazilians speak incorrect or broken
portuguese
[Music]
brazil the samples you just heard were
of the brazilian accent of brasilia
and the accent of lisbon portugal
there's a lot of variation within each
country as well but these two accents
are more or less representative of the
main differences between european
portuguese and brazilian portuguese
even if you don't know any portuguese
you may have noticed that something was
different about the way the two
varieties were pronounced
european portuguese is stress timed at
least to a large extent
i talked about european portuguese being
a stress-timed language
in my video explaining why portuguese
and russians sound similar
in a stress-timed language the length of
time between stressed syllables remains
relatively consistent
in order to fit into that relatively
fixed interval between stressed
syllables
unstressed syllables tend to become
shorter that results in lots of vowel
reduction
in contrast brazilian portuguese is
syllable timed
in syllable timed languages each
syllable lasts for a more or less equal
duration of time
lots of vowels that are reduced or
dropped in european portuguese are
generally pronounced more fully and
clearly in brazilian portuguese
for example this word meaning excellent
in european portuguese
iceland and in brazilian portuguese
another major difference in
pronunciation involves the l
sound in either language at the end of a
word or syllable
in european portuguese it's like a dark
l sound in brazilian portuguese it's
like a
like a w sound after a vowel for example
the word for couple
gazelle the sound represented by the
letter s
is also different in some contexts in
european portuguese it's
before a voiceless consonant even if
it's in the following word
and before a pause in other words at the
end of a word if there's nothing right
after it
in most brazilian accents it's before a
voiceless consonant and before a pause
for example the phrase meaning pretty
good vestent
bastanchibon note that in some brazilian
accents such as the carioca accent the
european sound is used
before a voiced consonant in european
portuguese it's
je in brazilian portuguese it's z in
most accents
for example the word meaning
note that between vowels it's z in both
european and brazilian accents
we saw this before in the word gazelle
caso
the r sound also differs between the two
countries depending on the context it
appears in
there's plenty of variation of the r
sound within each country too
but i'll try to give the general
tendencies when at the beginning of a
word or doubled
in european portuguese it's similar to a
french or german
are while in brazilian portuguese it's
for example
at the end of a syllable it's the same
as above in brazilian portuguese
in european portuguese it's normally an
alveolar tap
for example
note that between vowels or after a
consonant but before a vowel it's an
alveolar tap in both varieties
another characteristic difference is the
pronunciation of d
followed by i in portugal it's
pronounced
d or z usually when between vowels
in brazilian portuguese it's g for
example the word for day
tia there's a parallel difference in the
pronunciation of t
followed by i in portugal it's tea
though the vowel may be reduced in
unstressed syllables
in brazil it's for example the word for
ant
the brazilian sounds result from
palatalization
palatalization also occurs in d e and t
e
when they're unstressed with no accent
mark and when they're followed by a
in the next syllable that's because in
those cases the letter e
actually sounds like the letter i for
example verdaj
note that in some areas such as the
northeast of brazil
this palatalization doesn't occur the
portuguese varieties of portugal and
brazil share the vast majority of their
vocabulary but just like british people
and north american people use some
different vocabulary so do people from
portugal and brazil
the words for train in european
portuguese it's
but in brazilian portuguese it's which
comes from the english word tran
the words for catching a lift or
hitching a ride
the words for bathroom in portugal it's
cassette
which means house of bathing but in
brazil it's
interestingly in portugal this word
actually means lifeguard
the words for toilet senita
the words for fruit juice
breakfast this means little lunch
this means morning coffee refrigerator
in brazilian portuguese frigo is used
with the meaning of
meat processing plant i imagine it was
originally used to refer to a cold
storage facility for meat
let's look at a sentence for a second
there is milk and juice in the fridge
in portugal ah ladies and in brazil
in both varieties word for word it's
there is milk
and juice in the fridge aside from the
different vocabulary
notice the different pronunciation of
the word for milk
late late again we hear the difference
in how t e is pronounced when unstressed
the words for cell phone telemovel
the words for screen meaning the screen
of a tv or computer
in portugal it's ecre which comes from
french econ
in brazil it's taylor this word also
occurs in european portuguese but is
used for other types of screens or
canvases
not screens on electronic devices the
words for three-piece suit are different
the meaning of three-piece suit is
unique to brazilian portuguese but this
word exists in portuguese in general
with the meaning of trio
or set of three there are quite a few
words like that that have different
meanings in either country
sometimes their primary meaning is
different and sometimes there's an
additional meaning that doesn't exist in
the other country
in portugal this means t-shirt or
sweater camisole
in brazil it means night gown or night
dress some of these words can be a
little dangerous
in portugal this means boy
in brazil one meaning is to be really
angry
and another meaning is well a male
prostitute
similarly in portugal this means a young
lady
in brazil this means a female prostitute
for the meaning of a young lady in
brazilian portuguese the word
meaning can be used
in portugal this means university
tuition fee
in brazil it means a bribe there are a
few differences in grammar between
european and brazilian portuguese
second person singular pronouns european
portuguese uses two
as the familiar second person singular
pronoun and
vose as the informal but unfamiliar form
used with people of similar age or
status who you don't know very well
brazilian portuguese uses bose as the
informal second person singular pronoun
both familiar and unfamiliar this is
true in the standard form of brazilian
portuguese and in many dialects
though some dialects retain two for
example
you sing well in european portuguese
and in brazilian portuguese
but a kind of pronoun mixing often takes
place in brazilian portuguese with
voce being used as the subject pronoun
together with the equivalent of
tu as the object pronoun or the
possessive for example for the phrase
you and your son
you might hear this rather than this
however both of them are used in the
dialects of brazilian portuguese that do
use
to the conjugation for voce which is
really a third person singular
conjugation
is often used so again this is a kind of
mixed form that only occurs in brazil
placement of object pronouns object
pronouns in portuguese are normally
clitics that attach themselves close to
the verb
they are sometimes positioned
differently in the two varieties
in european portuguese they are often
enclitic placed after the verb
and in some cases are mesoclitic in the
middle of the verb
in brazilian portuguese they are
generally proclitic
meaning before the verb except in
compound tenses in which they come
after the auxiliary verb and before the
main verb for example
a sentence meaning he saw me in european
portuguese ilvium
and in brazilian portuguese in european
portuguese
mesocletic object pronouns are used in
the future indicative tense and the
conditional
in brazilian portuguese this is
considered archaic and it's rarely used
for example the sentence meaning i would
help you in european portuguese here
and in brazilian portuguese
notice how the object pronoun in
european portuguese is placed right
between the verb stem and its
inflectional ending
though this is a formal and literary
form
continuous forms continuous verb forms
like the present continuous are formed
differently
in brazilian portuguese it's istha plus
the gerund
but in european portuguese it's formed
with star
plus a plus the infinitive so take the
phrase for i'm speaking
in brazilian portuguese and in european
portuguese it's
stupid from what i understand this is
one difference that really really really
annoys portuguese speakers from portugal
who insist that it's terribly incorrect
portuguese
[Applause]
take this sentence we're learning
portuguese but it's difficult
first you can see the difference in the
present continuous tense that we talked
about a moment ago
aside from that these sentences are
pretty much the same except for their
pronunciation
in this word you can hear the difference
in the s sounds she
in european portuguese and in brazilian
portuguese
you can also hear the vowel reduction in
the european word with the first vowel
basically dropped
and notice this word difficile
in this word you can hear the brazilian
g sound at the beginning
while in the european word it's d you
can also hear the brazilian l
as it's pronounced at the end of a word
or syllable like
european portuguese and brazilian
portuguese are clearly varieties of the
same language
and in terms of grammar and vocabulary
they are the same for the most part
but as you saw earlier there are some
differences that really stand out when
you encounter them
especially words that have different
meanings in either variety
but the biggest difference lies in the
phonology of the two varieties
or their systems of pronunciation that's
probably the thing that often makes it
difficult for speakers of one variety to
understand the other
but that difference can be overcome by
learning about what's different between
the two varieties and gaining exposure
to the other one
but that's just how it seems to me what
do i know let's ask native speakers of
portuguese
the question of the day for native
speakers of european and brazilian
portuguese
how easy is it for you to understand and
communicate with speakers of the other
variety
and other people what do you think of
the differences between the two
varieties
how major do they seem to you i know
some of the people watching this video
already
know portuguese and others wish they
knew portuguese better
but isn't it time to stop wishing and
actually make it happen
and you can make it happen with
portuguese pod 101
portuguese pod 101 is produced by
innovative language who have
millions of members all over the world
they offer concise
easy to understand lessons that you can
complete at home in the car
or while waiting for your friend who
always shows up late improve your
listening and pronunciation with their
main audio lessons
improve your vocabulary with their
review tools and word lists
and learn all the basics of how the
language works with their simplified
grammar explanations
there's no better time than right now to
start learning portuguese
or whichever language you've always
wanted to learn click the link in the
description
or visit langfocus.com portuguesepod to
get started with a free account
i want to give a big shout out to all
the langfocus patreon members especially
the top tier patrons whose names appear
on the screen
other benefits including seeing videos
before everyone else
access to exclusive bonus videos and a
private langfocus online community
check out patreon.com langfocus to see
how you can become a patron
and to everyone thank you for watching
and have a nice
[Music]
day
[Music]
you